so they ever wonder why so few people
make it and real estate and mortgages
and insurance in any kind of sales why
do such a small percentage of people
make it I'm going to talk about that
today
I'm Patrick bit of your host evaluated
weekly and today I want you to look at
people who get whatever they want in a
complete different way I used to watch
people that got everything they wanted
to ask myself how is it that that person
got whatever he wanted or she wanted
there's a reason for that and the good
news is anybody else can do the same
thing as well this is not something
that's not transferable right selling is
something you'll always do the rest of
your life most people don't like selling
some people like to kind of make it nice
and sound we use a BET Award and say
communication or this it's sales by the
way those that just turn off the video
and don't want to watch about what
selling has to do here you want to marry
that girl you love you know which one
I'm talking about you need to sell her
and her parents and her best friends
that's all selling you want to get that
promotion purely selling baby and those
who get that promotion sell better than
you do that's why it is they don't sell
a car their job could be human resource
or something but they learn how to sell
themselves as that position more than
you maybe you ought to learn how to do
it'll benefit you make you a lot of
money kids is also selling businesses
selling a lot of things or so let me get
right into it the truth is there's a lot
more people starving in sales than
winning and the numbers are about 2% of
people that get what they want let me
give you a story here on what took place
with me in 2005 2006 the company I was a
part of announced a trip that we're
going to go to Europe it was a one-year
contest I was so excited about it right
and we were going to go to Greece
Santorini Athens Croatia Venice Italy I
really wanted to go on this trip well
it's the last month to qualify for this
trip and I'm in the running but I'm in
the bottom five people and two months
prior to that I asked my assistant I
said has my insurance license been
renewed because my license needed to be
renewed oh you've done everything
everything's good your life's gonna
renew you're good to go 100% hundred
percent bone first in a month get a
letter your license is expired I said
wait what is this is this a mistake he
says oh yeah this
mistake I'm not going to name my
assistant he knows who he is your
license is expired
well my license is expired your license
expired that's not possible
he calls yup we forgot two things to
send in my license is expired he asks
how long will it take for my license to
be renewed about two to four weeks
there's a lot of people in waiting lists
and if you know California Department of
Insurance they have a lot of people
trying to get licensed and appointed so
they're always backdated two to four
weeks that I can't afford to lose I'm
definitely not qualifying for this trip
so I said let me call them myself direct
we have two choices at that time one I
can think about firing him and how upset
I could be at him or whatever I could do
to the guy I did it because I want to go
to Europe it's more important my
frustration I can put into him same
amount of energy one takes me to Europe
one gets me upset at me
same amount of energy okay so I call
Department of Insurance I said I mean I
really need your help I really need you
to help me renew my life since it's
going to cost me a trip to Europe and I
please please you guys got to work with
me nope we can do no we can do no we can
do there's so many other people that
need to do this well I want to speak to
your manager not going to make a
difference let me just speak to your
manager not going to make a difference
please let me speak to your manager but
not upon with the manager I speak to
them until today I remember her name
because she really she really inspired
me that people out there actually
willing to help you out so I spoke to
the manager she retired three years
after them so I spoke to her and I said
look I really need to renew my license I
want to go to Europe and she says no can
either nothing for you so listen you got
to work with me nothing I tried every
single thing I could to get her to help
me renew my license said and I said said
her name and I said listen what if I
show up tomorrow morning six o'clock in
the morning at your front door when you
come into work with a box of doughnuts
and coffee and dozen roses just please
renew my license since Patrick's gonna
be waste your money we're not going to
do it you need to wait two to four weeks
I said I'm going to be in Sacramento
tomorrow don't do it that's how I
promise you I'll be there tomorrow I'm
gonna be there tomorrow
don't do it Patrick I said I know how to
sing many different songs I'm going to
sing I'm gonna dance in front of until
you renew my license so I asked my
system book to flight I go to sac
that night I get to the hotel I
explained whole thing to the assistants
from this clerk at the hotel and she's
laughing I said I need your help
and she said what me to do I said I need
you to call Starbucks to have two
gallons of coffee ready for me to have
those coffees on boxes you can buy I'm
not a coffee drinker but I know they
have it I said I want to buy 40
different sweets that they have whatever
it could be one of you to put it
together and I said I need fresh two
dozen roses in the morning as well great
go to sleep wake up six o'clock in the
morning I go to Starbucks pick up the
roses everything in front of the lot in
front of the Parminder it's a government
building type of thing where you know
how you go through the back door to
throw trash up it's not really an
entrance story there is no door to go
into this government building so I'm
outside but I know employees are coming
in so I asked around where do the
employees coming from right here and I'm
standing outside and I say hey it's
such-and-such theory yes she is
can you give this rose tour inside
teller Patrick made evidence waiting for
outside really yes would you like a cup
of coffee here's a cup of coffee here's
a cup of coffee Tom Patrick way they
serve at the serving cup of coffee
outside here's some donuts for here's
some of this for you eventually
I'm singing outside I'm just telling
them to bring those two girls outside
and no one's coming up five minutes
later ten minutes later thirty minutes
later one hour to three hours later she
comes outside she says what are you
doing here I said I told you I want to
be here I want to go to Europe I want to
go to Europe and I gotta get a point it
says Patrick no one's ever done this
before I said but you got to realize I
want to win for my family I gotta go to
Europe and after talking to her coffee
doughnuts
sweets roses she was such a sweet lady
she says Patrick we'll go ahead and
renew your license I says I'm not
leaving until I see it on the system I
waited outside she went inside they
renewed my license my friend from
Southern California calls and says
miracle your license has been renewed
and my license got renewed and the rest
is history until today I've been all
over the world the best place I've ever
visit in my life is Croatia de broglie
something special about Rosa Dubrovnik
had a great time why am I telling you
this story you see
in life you can have whatever you want
whatever you want now I'm not talking
about if you can't jump 48 inches like
some of these athletes I'm not talking
about if you don't run like a James jet
or or but some of these guys are run the
way that's a god-given different type of
a town I'm not talking about if you
can't sing like offer everything else is
tenacity and you settle yourself why
somebody ought to do what you want them
to do if you have a legitimate argument
with value and a little bit a sprinkle
of humor and humility helps as well if
you do that you will be surprised on how
much easier easier sales will sales will
be for you because people like doing
business with people who are tenacious
it's my message of the week - I'm please
be sure to subscribe on the bottom as
well as comment you hustler salesman and
one that's just simple is that what it
wasn't only starving starving Marvin
high-end quality to me with Subway's
six-inch you know to $2.99
that was pretty high-end stuff I thought
sushi was about going to the ocean and
cutting fish and just take a bite out of
it mahi Judy mahi Judy I'm Patrick way
to be the host of that
I'm Patrick bit I'm Patrick we live it
up you and Patrick they they make it for
Meg so let me get right into it I just
wasted like three minutes let's keep
going